foreign
seconds of previously awning nearly
everything about this establishing shot
is awesome but it's late runneth over
these probe droids are a notorious
Empire staple so how does one descending
from the heavens not raise all of the
the empires up to some shady red flags
or is this little critter permanently
chilling out around here like an
emergency brake glass in case of
exposition button report would it kill
people to just once use a damn screen
instead of a hologram especially in a
situation where you're trying to be
sneaky and perhaps don't want to be
visible from 360 Degrees also am I
supposed to be surprised the moth Gideon
turns up in the penultimate episode of
the Mandalorian because this is exactly
what happened in season one and that
brings us one occurrence away from it
becoming a clear this is the Shea and
make it quick as I am short on time
people who waste conversational Time by
telling people that they're short on
time before we continue Kane's report
doesn't need to be any more than the
following mandalorians including
denjaran defeated our pirates on Navarro
that's it nine words so I'm Addison for
every word over nine that waste moff
Gideon's time continue sir I'm afraid
the Pirates have run into trouble on
Navarro it wasn't the new Republic
magistrate cargo was aided by
mandalorians according to the reports
received but why do the police sirens in
this alien world in a different galaxy
look and sound exactly the same as ours
hmm all right for this room I want to go
with something minimalist but also
brooding so you know lots of concrete
and fall hazards of course and instead
of gaudy accents or wall decorations
just have two soul Two Soldiers staring
deeply into each other's eyes you know
what I love that last one so much put a
set of those every 10 feet are we
supposed to care about these tanks
probably am I going to care about these
tanks no
the new Republic is vulnerable we must
be cautious
show no sign of our true strength we now
bring you to the expositional Hologram
argument already in progress
return did you hear that that was the
sound of a million Geeks nerdgasming all
at once and on behalf of all of us
here's Us in for the unwelcome cleanup
operation we have to Embark upon
enough time oh mustn't forget to name
drop the dude that's the father of the
other dude that's being played by the
brother of the dude that played the
other dude is how I imagine this scene
was written perhaps it's time we look to
new leadership project Necromancer is a
place for that project Necromancer why
didn't they just call it project Super
Evil plan to assert Galactic villainy
and murder puppies also instead of being
far far away from the sequels we're
trying to fix the past like this is some
kind of Hot Tub Time Machine writers if
you wade into those Waters wearing this
much armor you risk developing some Rust
Victorian guards sounds like someone is
concerned about an assassination attempt
yeah but you are talking to a man that's
just recently escaped arrest by the new
Republic has a feud with the most
dangerous race of warriors in the galaxy
and whose 10-year career goals make
sauron's Master Plan look like a Dr
Seuss Adventure so yeah I'd say he's a
Target and maybe three guards with fly
zappers isn't too much to ask
considering all the that went down
with those pirates a few episodes ago
I'm gonna say these people are not
nearly concerned enough about this ship
flying overhead and how is grief done
nothing to maybe get a big freaking ship
alert before they're in spitting
distance of his office an imperial
shuttle is advancing over the city what
that is clearly not a shuttle first
that's a light Cruiser that was a trap
look at the markings see those my friend
Mandalorian privateers I thought to be a
magistrate you'd have to be at least
familiar with the concept of lying a few
simple markings and he's like no problem
come on in all it takes to get into his
plan is a big ass fake ID using your
Companion Cube to steady your vacuum
cleaner I hope these two groups get
along we've never met what little they
know of each other they hate this
comment along with the two minutes of
ship planning we had to sit through made
me think that this initial meeting of
these two groups would be interesting
and dramatic let us prepare a piece for
our guests and was not that's all the
way from Coruscant so you might want to
wait for a smaller gathering before you
open it or you know no gathering at all
considering the whole no eating no
drinking with your helmet on Deal come
to think of it gifting alcohol to a
Mandalorian is a pretty dick move
considering they have to drink it alone
that's not the only gift I have for you
that's a strange way to say I've created
a wearable battlebot for grogu from the
carcass of your friend what did you do
to ig-11 no that's ig-12 now you can't
expect to get away with removing
features that people want and replacing
them they didn't ask for by just
increasing the model number each year I
mean you can but only if you don't mind
being called an apple I mean an
well too little to operate this actually
he's the only size that can operate this
thing but the confusing bit has to do
with the fact that Mando's opinion goes
from you're too little to follow me into
battle by the end of the episode
seemingly based only on grogu's ability
to terrorize a street vendor maybe when
he's older no
what do you mean no
kogu learning his first word and
continuing to troll Mando is just
hilarious how do these two get even more
adorable with time yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes
yes this isn't working for me your
Apprentice puppeteering the husk of the
planet's savior to steal fruit I should
hope so and why are we being forced to
watch this instead of what's going on
with the two groups of mandalorians that
hate each other's guts
manic our homework
I mean it'll get a sin for being a
cliche but I do love me a good rousing
halftime speech the remaining magnetic
interference has made it impossible to
scan the surface from above atmosphere
which is why I'm proposed
into orbit above Mandalore false alarm
just for standard exposition's in also
you don't know what's on the planet yet
you're gonna Park your entire fleet
above it I'm no expert in military
strategy but it seems like there might
be one or two situations where that's a
bad idea like I don't know maybe it's a
trap I need volunteers from both tribes
writers make us suffer through the
required hesitation until our brave and
selfless Mando finally stands up and
volunteers thereby unlocking the
logarithmic growth curve of volunteering
until we're all standing on our desks
and not a single one of these
says O Captain my Captain I will go grow
go as well I don't think Mando
understands how volunteering works also
sometimes Amanda wants to protect grogu
and other times it's just like he wants
to put him In Harm's Way I mean I'm fine
with either I just wish it made sense
for the character and not just the story
once everyone agrees to join the Journey
to the Center of Mandalore Expedition we
have just over five minutes of departing
transiting arriving sitting falling and
ordering before anything vaguely new or
interesting happens yes the fleet and
the ODS team look cool but could we have
also had some conversational meat on the
bone between these opposing factions
we'll lose cons shortly and conveniently
we'll survey the surface until we find
origin create a safety zone does this
require you to subject us to more
footage of mandalorians getting their 10
000 steps in because you said magnetic
interference has made has made it
possible to stand
now we don't know what's preventing you
from using your space plane to scan the
surface from a lower altitude this part
of badassery thing is cool can't
wait to see Many Adventures with this
awesome it's not gonna make it to the
end of the episode is it they punish us
as a warning to the whole galaxy because
we refuse to surrender that's not true I
did surrender this shocking Revelation
is played like it's going to lead to
feelings of betrayal among the surviving
Mandos and possibly further division
between the factions but nope everyone's
super chill about it because we waited
until the penultimate episode to get
here and don't have time for pesky
things like character development after
our forces were annihilated in the a
thousand tears this event isn't called
the Knight of a thousand retellings of
how many times do I have to hear about
Mandalore being bombed we get it it
sucked also a thousand sounds like a lot
but it really isn't when you put it in
terms of Tears two tear ducts per person
means 500 people at most cried over this
tragedy and that's assuming they only
shed one tear from each eye those of you
who are well enough can join us in the
search
we can bring you there all right finally
some excitement Hoist the top sales
batten down the hatches and other
boating terms let's go
damn it
should I step in neither side can step
in which is something Mando should know
but conveniently doesn't and something
the audience doesn't know but could have
figured out from Context Clues
this welcome break in the monotony of
boat life is Tainted by the confusing
physics aboard this vessel that allowed
ax to be attacking from the port side in
this shot then starboard side in this
shot then back to the port side in this
shot
as well and learn that from me this
response to Goku stopping the fight is
super confusing coming from the person
who a moment ago said neither side can
step in so is grogu's lack of creed some
sort of bureaucratic loophole or did he
just out himself as a spy either way
everyone's being okay with this seems
like some convoluted I guess
this ship has been returning to the
fleet for the past three minutes and
that's important to us for reasons other
than this discount Interstellar shot but
we won't find that out in this episode
so in the end this is just more waiting
for something to happen during this very
exciting retaking of Mandalore
on the Storm
point of a spotter is if the plan post
spotting is to just plow forward with no
attempt at course correction directly
into the thing that they tell you
they've spotted
did someone on the writing team not want
them to have the cool boat anymore
because otherwise this doesn't feel like
the big deal it should be we have no
idea how many Mandos were injured and it
turns out the abandoned ship at a pretty
ideal place to continue to the forge on
foot at least that'll be the only
pointless sacrifice of this episode
making us momentarily believe this might
be a major setback only to reveal that
the creature just helped them get off at
the right exit
the momentary coolness of this idea
quickly faded once I realized the big
reveal of everyone having Mandalorian
armor just makes this your typical same
versus same matchup
cover
now I'm no Mandalorian nor have I fought
in anything scarier than a pillow fight
but I've seen this cliche enough to know
that covering fire works by you laying
down a ton of fire which causes the
enemy to hide and in turn provides a
small window of time for your buddy to
do what they need to do this was mainly
ax watching Paz kill people these pescar
Laden jump Troopers suck a little less
at shooting than the normal ones it's as
if Star Wars is trying to blame
Stormtrooper aim on the fact that their
helmets didn't have the split down the
front a feature that I thought was only
there for increased visibility during
urination this individual appears to
have been committed to walking backwards
off of this ledge before they were even
shot also this individual has a jet pack
as does this one this Rocket Man flying
right into this clothesline maybe the
first ever example of Stormtrooper
piloting instead of attacking or
defending this guy uses his face to
Blaster style because they trained him
wrong on purpose as a joke
why is he even here though no other
mandalorians brought foundlings on this
field trip this completely unnecessary
jump shot moff Gideon makes his sexy boy
WrestleMania entrance and I believe
we're supposed to be impressed that
they've added Rockets to a Darth Vader
or not but we might have been had they
not already added Rockets to everyone
else I have created the Next Generation
Dark Trooper suit forged from best scar
does he need to expose it about how The
Empire is just getting around and making
armor out of a metal alloy instead of a
PVC pipe probably not and the most
impressive Improvement is that it has me
saying this instead of showing us an
actual upgrade Hollow vids or it didn't
happen off we got to grogu just in time
to remember Mando's bad parenting and
acknowledged that he came all the way
down here in a mech suit to do
absolutely nothing
pretty packaging as you like but
Stormtroopers will still just blindly
run into the oncoming fire instead of
using any kind of cover or Advantage
when the story needs them to go
on his own so no there aren't too many
also I guess no Adventure would be
complete without the needless sacrifice
of a fairly well-liked ancillary
character this one feels especially
needless considering everyone's already
escaped and if the jump Troopers want to
pursue they'd have to pass through a
nasty bottleneck look if you've got a
martyr boner then just say so but don't
make it out like this was your only
option
[Music]
these individuals have jet packs the
praetorian guards show up just after the
battle to make sure that no one ever
finds out how wrong pass was about the
number of jump Troopers episode
contained very few spies or so we think
thank you
[Music]
why didn't you just go home that's your
home are you too good for your home
hello and welcome to the Los Pollos
Hermanos family my name is Gustavo but
you can call me Gus report
and make it quick as I am short on time
actually you called me oh hell let's
just do what we always do hijackson
nuclear weapons and hold the world
hostage that's right that's right that's
ig-12 now do you like him this is some
up Republicans too young to
operate heavy machinery maybe when he's
older
what do you mean no
I look around I see these young faces
and I think I mean I made every wrong
choice a middle-aged man can make
[Music]
we'll make it back
what is this place
Chantel love could it be a trap I will
create an army
that will bring order to the Galaxy
there's no order no discipline it's a
jet pack